les halles de paris c'est donc reparti
pour parler un langage disons un peu
populaire vingt ans après la décision de
transférer les marchés a rungis il ya la
villette la controverse sur
l'utilisation du ventre de paris se
poursuit
eh oui que va-t-on faire du carreau des
halles pour le conseil de paris en tout
cas il n'y a plus de problème il y a
quatre mois le conseil a adopté un
projet projet d'ailleurs présenté par le
maire de paris monsieur chirac mais
disons qu'en ce moment tout le monde
n'est pas content de cette décision et
certains critiques ont lancé une
consultation internationale consultation
qui devrait aboutir à l'élaboration et
qui a abouti à l'élaboration d'un
contre-projet
voilà l'état actuel donc du dossier
aujourd'hui monsieur jacques chirac qui
nous écoutent dans son bureau de l'hôtel
de ville de paris nous dira tout à
l'heure où l'on en est avant
remettons-nous un petit peu si vous
voulez bien le dossier en tête voilà
près de 25 ans en effet que l'on parle
des halles de paris
un dossier préparé par jean pellieux
construit dans le style voulu par
napoléon iii en fer et en fonte
les pavillons de baltard seront de 1857
à 1971 le plus grand centre
d'alimentation du monde ainsi qu'un
exceptionnel lieu d'animation 1959 on
décide le transfert d al araji et la
villette 1968 un concours est lancé pour
réaménager le quartier on veut tout
logement loisirs centre de commerce
international
jardin six projets d'architectes sont
retenus parmi lesquels celui de faugeron
détour monumental avec jardins suspendus
aucun n'est choisi 1971 malgré les
protestations ont démoli les pavillons
pendant deux ans il s'était animée
nouveau théâtre musique expositions et
cetera le silence retombe sur les débris
des halles
et puis en outre 74 rebondissements à la
demande du chef de l'état on décide
d'abandonner le centre de commerce et
d'agrandir le jardin nouvelle
consultation d'architectes reçu à
l'elysée ricardo beau fils apparaît
comme le favori avec son jardin
monumentale et son architecture néo
orientale novembre soixante dix huit
nouveaux changements
valéry giscard d'estaing abandonne à
jacques chirac l'aménagement des halles
le maire de paris retire a beau fils la
construction des ihm
bleu destiné à masquer la centrale de
climatisation voilà vingt ans en tout
cas que le transfert des halles a été
décidé et le centre de paris est
toujours en chantier
hal est pourtant sous sol les travaux
ont abouti
catherine de métro urbain deux lignes de
métro régional
plus de cent mille personnes par heure
peuvent se croiser dans la plus grande
gare souterraine du monde des rues
souterraine aussi des bouches comme les
accès du métro sur le forum le forum
sera inaugurée en septembre prochain
pôle d'attraction commerciales avec ses
200 magasins il accueille aussi des
manifestations culturelles notamment
dans son cratère dont les arts cintrée
répondent à ceux de saint-eustache le
sous-sol s'achève et la surface les
hésitations doivent cesser affirme
jacques chirac qui en mars dernier
présente son projet fin en 1983 en bas
de votre écran un jardin à la française
une place à l'italienne en sous sol
divers équipements sportifs et culturels
pour les enfants à l'est en haut de
l'écran des terrasses plantées d'arbres
comme pour le jardin abandon du
monumental pour les bâtiments futures
qui devront s'harmoniser avec
l'environnement le point fort du
quartier existe déjà c'est le centre
beaubourg avec lequel le maire de paris
veut développer les liaisons piétonnes
le projet chirac adopté par les élus il
n'y aurait plus qu'à attendre que le
trou des halles soient comblées eh bien
non le débat n'est pas clos pour
certains critiques qui ont lancé une
consultation internationale afin
d'aboutir à un contre-projet sur les
halles